pour pensez vous que l'humour de jean
michel maire fait de l'ombre à jean luc
lemoine pour moi la réponse est non mais
jean michel maire y croit dur comme fer
n'est ce pas jean lui tout à fait on
ressent le paravent aux six mois semaine
de chacun mais il se prend vraiment pour
le sniper de l'émission ouais et laisser
jean luc faire mais vous êtes un très
bon élève
regardez lui c'est jean michel mr plus
connu sous le nom du relou dur marc ou
encore de l'autre kong depuis de
nombreuses années cet ancien reporter de
guerre qui a fait le tour du monde
entier est devenu un chroniqueur
indispensable ne touche pas à mon poste
comme il aime à le dire il est rentré
dans l'amour dans le moule
il a même développé un certain sens de
l'humour seulement voilà de l'autre côté
de la table ça ne passe pas jean luc
lemoine rit jaune depuis peu l'humoriste
créateur des quatre tiers également féru
de déguisements se retrouve dans une
situation délicate
en effet il est désormais en concurrence
avec jean michel merle homme à l'humour
d'une grande finesse
vous l'aurez compris l'humour à un
nouveau visage
alors pensez vous que l'humour de jean
michel maire c'est de l'ombre à jean luc
lemoine
sur cette séquence jean luc lemoine
at-il bandé et surtout pourquoi jean
michel may hamm est il des costumes qui
lui vont comme un gland autant de
questions auxquelles l'inspecteur baba
va tenter de répondre alors jean-michel
dit la vérité est au rendez-vous fait de
longs mois jean agent lui oui oui mais
je l'admiré beaucoup et pire il faut
respecter les anciens je pense que je
pense que je vais plutôt pour être exact
ringardisé succès c'est l'humour qui
nous tenaille par un ancien moi c'est
une star hyper moderne et sociale c'est
ça qu'est ce qu'on a vu c'est ce que je
vous rappelle que me dicte des gens dans
la rue léger d'accord j'ai compris mais
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous parler
français écoutez je pense que il a
raison et la raison ils inventer quelque
chose
une nouvelle forme de sniping on va dire
c'est à dire que normalement un sniper
c'est quelqu'un qui a un fusil de
précision qui tirait qui fait mouche lui
fait du stenting à la mitraillette
donc il en faut par tous et de toutes il
ya une qui touche c'est à dire que c'est
un bon résumé jean michel et j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour lui et je
laisse ma place bien volontiers non
merci on admire beaucoup merci banos si
moi aussi je voulais un beau coup vous
ai je fait sûrement rhji chroniqueur
officiel c'est pour lui ce serait mon
tapis rien